my name is Brittany Baldwin I'm a junior
at Hillsdale College in American Studies
major I am currently interning at the
Heritage Foundation as part as the as
part of the Washington Hillsdale
internship program Paul Moreno is a
senior fellow with the kirby center the
William and Bernice grew [ __ ] chair and
constitutional history the dean of
faculty and an associate professor of
history at Hillsdale College he has
earned his ba magna [ __ ] lot and his MA
at the state university of new york at
albany and his PhD in history from the
University of Maryland at College Park
dr. Marino has served as a Jon ollen
Junior Fellow and as a James Madison
fellow at Princeton University he has
published widely in journals such as law
and history review the Journal of
southern history and the Journal of
policy history he has also contributed
to numerous encyclopedias including the
Heritage guide to the Constitution and
the encyclopedia of labor and
working-class history his book includes
black Americans in organized labor a new
history and from direct action to
affirmation action Fair Employment Law
and Policy in America please join me in
welcoming dr. Paul Murray know who is
speaking on the topic of how our
economic Liberty has been diminished
Thank You Brittany for that introduction
I'd like to thank Hillsdale College in
the kirby center for inviting me here
today to speak with you it's a great
honor I'm going to be talking this
morning about the founders idea of
economic liberty and how we lost it so I
have some good news for you and some
some bad news first though we need to
lay out what was the founders idea of
economic liberty basically it was that a
free economy would promote the moral
character needed for Republican
self-government it was part of their
idea that if people are going to govern
themselves politically they had to
govern themselves in their families in
their churches in their communities and
in economic markets this idea came most
immediately from Enlightenment thinkers
of England and Scotland especially and
we tend to focus on John Locke and
rightly so though there's more to the
story than then lock for locks ideas
were deeply rooted in classical and
medieval thought of Aristotle and his
early modern scholastic followers is
Jefferson and self put it in the
Declaration of Independence he was just
summarizing all the great thinkers of
political right Aristotle Cicero Sydney
and unlock and I'm emphasizing in this
treatment the continuity between the
ancient the medieval and modern somewhat
controversial point among scholars but
at Hillsdale College our curriculum was
based on the idea that the
judeo-christian faith and greco-roman
culture finds its clearest expression in
the American experiment of liberty under
law but our students read Aristotle who
says quote that any polis which is a
true political community and not merely
one a name must devote itself to the end
of encouraging goodness otherwise the
political association sinks into a mere
Alliance and law becomes a mere covenant
as the Sophists say a guarantor of men's
rights against one another instead of
being as it should be a rule of life
that will make the members of the
political community and good and just
many people would say that the founders
established exactly what Aristotle
condemns here as a bogus polis our
republic is founded on the principle
that individuals have certain rights and
the governments are instituted to secure
those
but this view takes a very shallow idea
of what rights are and of property
rights in particular certainly there
were significant differences between
ancient and modern Republican ideas of
liberty nevertheless the modern
liberalism of the founders did not sever
the connection between morals and
government and to make this point I'd
like to read a little bit from the
political scientist Martin diamonds
essay ethics and politics the American
Way Diamond says while the American
founders turned away from the classic
Enterprise regarding virtue they did not
thereby abandon the pursuit of virtue or
excellence in all other possible ways in
fact the American political order Rises
high enough above the vulgar level of
mere self-interest in the direction of
virtue if not to the highest reaches of
the ancient perspective still towards
positive human decencies or excellences
indeed the prospect of excellences is
opened up even within the very
commercial interest the unleashing of
which is requisite to Madison's scheme
as Alexis de Tocqueville said sermon
about the Americans in the 19th century
there was something heroic about
American business enterprise and the
founders understood that we couldn't
cure people of their tendency to desire
material goods but we could construct a
regime in which that pursuit would take
place only in honest ways and in ways
that promoted good traits of character
but acquisitiveness teaches a form of
moderation to the desiring passions from
which it derives because to acquire is
not primarily to have and to hold but to
get into earn and moreover to earn
justly at least to the extent that the
acquisition must be the fruit of one's
own exertions or qualities this requires
the acquisitive man to cultivate certain
excellences minimal ones perhaps from
the classical perspective but
excellences nonetheless as means to
achieve his ends he wants in large
so as to allow time for the ripening of
his acquisitive plans and measures in
short acquisitive man unlike avaricious
man is likely to have at least what we
call the bourgeois virtues one of the
most common criticisms of the founders
and has begun by the progressives about
a hundred years ago was that they were
only concerned with property rights with
economic stuff that wealthy landowners
and merchants wrote the Constitution and
that later on stockholders and
bondholders ran the government and they
didn't care about non-economic rights
nothing could be further from the truth
the founders had an expansive definition
of property John Locke said though the
earth and all inferior creatures are
common to all men yet every man has a
property in his own person this nobody
has any right to but himself the labor
of his body and the work of his hands
are properly his wenlock wanted to talk
about material possessions land chattels
cash or jewelry he used the term estates
lock also gave us the famous labor
theory of value by which one came to
possess something by mixings one mixing
one's labor with it James Madison held a
similar view in 1792 he wrote the essay
that congressman Spence just quoted from
explaining that the term property
embraces everything to which a man may
attach a value and have a right and
which leaves to everyone else the like
advantage a man has a property in his
opinions and the free communication of
them he has a property of peculiar value
in his religious opinions and in the
possession and practice dictated by them
he's a property very dear to him in the
safety and liberty of his person he has
an equal property in the free use of his
faculties or talents we would say and
the free choice of objects on which to
employ them and a word as a man is said
to have a right to his property he may
be equally said to have a property in
his rights the Constitution meant to
protect those rights our talents beliefs
and opinions as well as our material
possessions because these possessions
came from nature and from nature's God
in a free and just society but all we
would all have the Liberty to use our
property for ourselves our families and
our communities
material award would be the prob would
be the product of virtuous behavior and
if we use our property to indulge in
vicious behavior we would probably lose
it the founders also understood that
since God in nature distributed talents
unevenly social and economic inequality
would result even in or we might say
especially in a fair and just society
Madison said in the 10th Federalist that
quote the diversity and the faculties or
abilities of men from which the rights
of property originate r is an
insuperable obstacle to a uniformity of
interests as a result interest group
factionalism is inevitable in Republican
governments but he said the protection
of these unequal faculties is the first
object of government Madison goes on to
talk about the various ways in which the
proposed Constitution would help prevent
such destructive factionalism of the
kind that the founders had seen in most
of the states in the 1780s most of these
faxes activities involve state
legislatures enacting laws to relieve
debts in the 10th Federalist Madison
explained how one element of the
Constitution the idea of the extended
republic would help prevent the tyranny
of a majority faction a rage for
property he said for an abolition of
debts for an equal division of property
or for any other improper or wicked
project will be less apt to pervade the
whole body of the Union than a
particular member of it other features
of the Constitution the separation of
powers checks and balances federalism
and the enumeration of legislative power
and an independent judiciary would also
help several particular provisions of
the Constitution addressed economic
justice the wicked project of paper
money for example was forbidden to the
states in article 1 section 10 and most
important states were forbidden to pass
any laws and pairing the obligation of
contracts language that was taken from
the Northwest Ordinance the Supreme
Court under John Marshall was especially
vigorous in using the contract clause to
prevent state legislation that
redistributed property in a way that
Marshall said quote destroys the
confidence of man in man and made it
impossible to lend or invest and perhaps
nobody benefited more from Marshalls
contract clause during
prudence than Hillsdale College in 1819
Marshall held that private college
charters were contracts which state
legislatures could not invade when they
didn't like the political principles of
the college Marshall and his successor
Roger tawny who would have gone down in
history is a great jurist had it not
been for the Dred Scott decision
preserve the constitutional safeguards
of a free economy the result was
astonishing economic growth in America
before the Civil War Abraham Lincoln
considering the source of the great
prosperity of the United States said all
this is not the result of accident it
has a philosophical cause without the
Constitution in the Union we could not
have attained the result but even these
are not the primary cause of our great
prosperity there is something back of
these in twining itself more closely
about the human heart that's something
is the principle of Liberty to all the
principle that clears the path for all
gives hope to all and by consequence
gives enterprise and industry to all the
civil war itself was fundamentally about
economic Liberty the secessionists
rejected the Constitution the principles
of the Declaration of Independence and
the whole modern natural rights
tradition the most extreme of them
justified not just the enslavement of
Africans but of all man George
Fitzhugh's book sociology for the South
was subtitled a failure of free society
fits you like many early labor union
leaders argued that southern chattel
slavery was superior to northern free
labor which they scoffed at as quote
wage slavery while southern chattel
slavery provided a cradle-to-grave
welfare state for the slaves northern
capitalists exploited their workers
while they were productive and just
discarded them afterwards Lincoln on the
other hand expressed the faith in the
free labor philosophy of the North he
denied that there were any fixed social
classes in the North no permanent
proletariat a man could begin by working
for others and if he practiced the
bourgeois virtues eventually rise to be
self employed and eventually to employ
others the persistent inequality of
American history does not belie
Lincoln's argument as economists like
Thomas Sowell have pointed out
statistics about unequal income
distribution over time don't tell us who
the people are in the percentile
categories in fact there is and was a
high degree of social mobility
throughout American history enough to
attract some 25 million immigrants to
the United States between the Civil War
and World War 1 nobody can deny the
rapid economic growth of the late 19th
century the so-called Gilded Age and
it's material benefits every indicator
of economic well-being rose across the
board in these years so you may wonder
what was all the fuss about in the late
19th century barber there's so many
complaints about the economy from the
populist progresses the New Deal
liberals let alone from the anarchist
socialists and communists again the
aggregate economic statistics don't tell
the whole story human beings are
individuals not statistical aggregates
and while there is no doubt that society
as a whole or people were better off
there's also no doubt that many
particular persons or groups were worse
off again while there was a great deal
of social mobility and the overall a
growth curve was upward some sale while
others rose technological advances
especially raised overall economic
welfare but displays particular business
men and their workers how many harness
makers did Henry Ford put out of
business how many independent oil
refiners were ruined by the greater
efficiency of Standard Oil this is part
of the creative destruction of free
market economic growth mom and pop
groceries fall to supermarkets and
supermarkets fall to walmart the source
of most of the American labor movement
in the late 19th century which were
skilled artisans who skills were
threatened by economic change moreover
even if an individual was better off
from year to year he meant he might not
be as much better off as some of his
neighbor's individual human beings often
estimate their condition not in absolute
but in relative terms we are after all
social animals and we are also prone to
envy also the economic growth was uneven
there were booms and busts bubbles and
panics the business cycle many people
found this unsettling the rapid growth
was unpredictable disorderly
disorienting as we move from a rural and
small-town to an urban and in
Society it was the most fundamental
change in human history since the shift
from hunting and gathering to settled
agriculture poverty might be reduced but
we saw a new kind of poverty urban more
visible and often composed of new
immigrants finally well there's no
dispute about the material benefits of
industrialization there were spiritual
or aesthetic costs the smoke the noise
the environmental degradation what
economists call negative externalities
thus the most steadfast critics of
industrialism were poets and artists we
must also consider the claims that the
means by which the late 19th century
Republicans promoted economic
development were illegitimate and
unconstitutional when the republican
party came to power in 1861 they did not
just end slavery save the Union and go
out of business they also put into place
a system of national mercantilism that
Alexander Hamilton and Henry Clay had
promoted before the Civil War most
Republicans after all had been wigs so
we got a protective tariff great
subsidies to build Transcontinental
railroads and the national banking
system I think that these programs were
within the constitutional power of the
national government and that they were
for the most part genuinely in the
national or public interest but it's not
an open-and-shut case and it is open to
legitimate criticism these unsettling
aspects of the Industrial Revolution
were bound to put pressure on the
Constitution especially when the
grievances were concentrated in certain
sections of the country the agricultural
south and west in particular there were
innumerable cases where interest groups
called upon the government to do
something to relieve their economic
distress there were countless examples
but one of the best is the dairy farmers
campaign against margarine commonly
called oleo margarine back then oleo
margarine was invented by a french
chemist shortly after the Civil War and
this animal fat substitute for butter
retailed at about half the price of
butter the dairy Lobby made all kinds of
extravagant claims about the harmful
effects of oleo and that it was colored
yellow and sold fraudulently as butter
the dairyman tried to tax it out of
existence or to require that it be
colored pink or blue to repel customers
the term for laws like this was class
legislation the use of public power not
for the public good but for a private
interest
action in Madisonian terms the federal
courts were the most important protector
of economic liberty in the late 19th
century when most class legislation
emanated from the states but it is
important to recognize that the federal
courts only rarely overturn such acts
the progressives later depicted the
federal judiciary as routinely using the
14th amendment to strike down state
socio-economic regulations at the behest
of big business in fact the courts
usually accepted the flimsiest of
pretexts that such acts were genuine
exercises of what is known as the police
power the constitutionally reserved
power of the states to legislate to
preserve the safety health welfare and
morals of the people the poster child
for this alleged lays a fair
jurisprudence is Lochner against New
York a 1905 case in which the Supreme
Court overturned a law that limited the
number of hours that Baker's could work
historians have lately come to recognize
that decisions like Lochner were in fact
rare but they have still not recognized
that the act in question was indeed a
piece of class legislation in this case
large unionized bakeries mostly composed
of older Western European immigrants
were trying to limit the competition of
non-union bakeries using newer
immigrants from Eastern Europe just this
year professor david bernstein of george
mason university has published a book
called rehabilitating Lochner defending
individual rights against progressive
reform that tells the whole story in
fact the typical case of the era was not
locked nerd but Plessy against Ferguson
in which the Supreme Court blithely
accepted Louisiana's argument that
segregating the races on streetcars
serve the legitimate purpose of
maintaining peace between the races but
from time to time the court did give
expression to the fundamental founding
era principles of property rights when
it struck down state legislation for
example when the Louisiana State
Legislature dealt with the genuine
public health problem of butchers who
simply dumped their waste into the
Mississippi River upstream from a
populous city it did so by establishing
a monopoly slaughterhouse the
incorporators of which appeared to have
bribed the legislature to grant them the
privilege the Supreme Court narrowly
upheld this ordinance but just as
Stephen filled in his dissent provided a
ringing defense of natural
rights he said by the Louisiana law the
right of free labor one of the most
sacred and in prescriptive all rights of
man is violated grants of exclusive
privileges are opposed to the whole
theory of free government and it
requires no aid from any bill of rights
to render them void that only is a free
government in the American sense of the
term under which the inalienable right
of every citizen to pursue his happiness
is unrestrained except by just equal and
impartial laws The Last Stand of the old
regime of property rights can be seen in
the response to the depression of 1893
Grover Cleveland was President a
Democrat who was more faithful to the
principles of economic Liberty the most
Republicans he responded to the crisis
by refusing to promote inflation to
maintain the government's credit in the
gold standard and to use federal forces
to prevent the american railway Union
from paralyzing the national
transportation system the Democrats
repudiated Cleveland in 1896 and
nominated William Jennings Bryan but
Cleveland's principles triumph when the
American people returned the Republicans
in that election the principal cause of
the decline of economic liberty after
this in the 20th century was the
rejection of the founders philosophical
belief about the source of Rights we saw
the defeat of a similar challenge to
those principles in secession and the
Civil War but in a sense the losing side
in the Civil War ended up winning the
intellectual argument later in the
century the intellectual movements of
the 19th century have been called by
various names materialism scientism
positivism historicism they all shared a
common premise that there were no
eternal fixed absolute truths or
standards they rejected the idea of
nature and nature's God and claimed that
everything was contingent upon the
particular times places and
circumstances everything was evolving
developing historical consequently there
were no self-evident truths and the
Constitution could not be read as
embodying any such truths taken together
these intellectual theories came to be
called progressivism in the United
States there are lots of varieties and
differences among the progressives but
they shared a common belief that since
human beings could alter their
environment they could control
all their own evolution this meant that
the power of the government had to be
increased in order to deal with the
problems that evolutionary development
had caused those problems of the
industrial and urban revolutions I'm
going to focus on progressive ideas in
the field of law and constitutional law
in particular but they had a much wider
application for example progresses
promoted a profound change in private
law torts contracts and things like that
which had an enormous economic impact
but we don't have time to cover it all
the main intellectual source of
progressivism in law was Harvard Law
School who's Dean a man named
Christopher Columbus langdale began to
teach law as the Natural Sciences were
taught Langille was a botanist and
believe that you could study law just as
you studied plants and that law evolved
just as plants evolved Rosco pound the
founder of the movement known as
sociological jurisprudence was also a
botanist another set of critics of
American constitutionalism came from the
analytical or utilitarian school of law
which can trace its origin to Thomas
Hobbes and Jeremy Bentham and others as
Benson put it natural rights is simple
nonsense natural and prescriptive all
rights rhetorical nonsense nonsense on
stilts for these thinkers law was not
something that existed apart from man it
was not given by God or nature to be
discovered by men rather law was simply
the will of the sovereign as William
Graham Sumner a leading American
sociologist and social Darwinist at Yale
put it nothing but might has ever made
right these critical theories came
together in Oliver Wendell Holmes jr.
perhaps the best-known jurist in
American history Holmes had been an
ardent abolitionist and enlisted in the
union army and fought bravely and was
wounded three times the lesson that he
learned from the war was that ideas have
consequences six hundred and twenty
thousand men died because people took
ideas like the moral wrongness of
slavery seriously so he concluded that
people should not believe in moral
absolutes in self-evident truths in
natural rights President Theodore
Roosevelt appointed homes to the Supreme
Court in 1902 because he thought Holmes
would support the administration's
policies especially on imperialism
Roosevelt was a Darwinist himself and
scoffed at constitutional limitations
he wanted to make sure that the
liberties of the bill of rights were not
extended to America's new territories
like the Philippines homes and along
with this because he believed that the
law had nothing to deal with moral
principle he would prefer he wrote that
every word of moral significance be
banished from the law altogether and
other words adopted which should convey
legal ideas uncolored by anything
outside the law manifestly he said
nothing but confusion of thought can
result from assuming that the rights of
man in a moral sense are equally rights
in the sense of the Constitution and the
laws thus Holmes had no problem with
class legislation he said it is not
sufficient condemnation of legislation
that it favors one class at the expense
of another for much or all legislation
does that legislation is necessarily a
means by which a body having the power
puts burdens which are disagreeable to
them onto the shoulders of somebody else
Holmes himself admitted that his
philosophy came devilishly close to
believing that might makes right Holmes
is probably best remembered for his
dissent in the Lochner case when the
court overturned the maximum our law for
bakers this case is decided upon an
economic theory which a large part of
the country does not entertain he said
the Fourteenth Amendment does not enact
mr. Herbert Spencer's social statics
ironically Holmes is the only real
Darwinist on the court and he was
accusing his brethren of being
darwinists which they were not indeed
one cannot find any trace of Darwinian
philosophy among the conservative
judicial opinions of the late 19th early
20th century they still depended upon
the moral social and political
philosophy of the founders these
progressive ideas gradually infiltrated
the universities the law schools
legislators and the courts the process
took several decades and is still going
on today the campaign proceeded in fits
and starts the first step was the
establishment of so-called independent
regulatory commissions the so-called
fourth branch of government agencies
that combined legislative executive and
judicial powers what Madison called the
very definition of despotism the first
of these was the Interstate Commerce
Commission formed in 1887 to regulate
railroads in its early years the I
CC was quite weak in part because the
first Commissioner still had
constitutional scruples but also because
Congress have given the condition and
impossibly contradictory mission and
also because federal judges kept it on a
tight leash one can also say the
railroads were a special case a natural
monopoly or public utility that
genuinely needed federal supervision
over time though more commissions were
established with more power the Federal
Trade Commission in 1914 the National
Labor Relations Board in 1935 the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission in
1964 the list goes on and on to give you
an illustration of the constitutional
problem presented by these agencies let
me read this amusing but accurate
description of how the Federal Trade
Commission works by Boston University
law professor gary larson the Commission
promulgates substantive rules of conduct
also known as laws the Commission then
can authorize investigation into whether
the Commission's rules have been
violated if the Commission authorizes
such an investigation the investigation
is conducted by the Commission which
reports its findings to the Commission
if the Commission thinks that the
Commission's findings warrant an
enforcement action the Commission issues
a complaint the Commission's complaint
that a commission rule has been violated
is then prosecuted by the Commission and
adjudicated by the Commission this
commission adjudication can take place
either before the full commission or
before a semi-autonomous commission
administrative law judge if the
Commission chooses to adjudicate before
an administrative law judge rather than
before the Commission and the decision
is adverse to the Commission the
Commission can appeal to the Commission
if the Commission ultimately finds a
violation then and only then the
affected party can appeal to an article
three court but the agency decision even
before the bona fide article three
tribunal possesses a very strong
presumption of correctness on matters of
both fact and law another source of
government power was the extension of
Congress's power to regulate interstate
commerce into an all-purpose police
power this all started innocently enough
Congress first went after subjects that
were overwhelmingly unpopular making it
a crime to transport lottery tickets
across state lines a century ago no
state had a lottery
States prohibited rather than promoted
you handling or making it a crime to
transfer women across state lines for
immoral purposes msn a century ago
nobody defended prostitution the Supreme
Court upheld all of these but during
World War one it drew the line when
Congress applied these powers to goods
manufactured by child labor during the
1920s the court maintained an uneasy
balance as to how far the federal
government could take its Commerce and
taxing powers ultimately these
extensions of the commerce power and the
administrative state were the most
important threats to economic Liberty in
the 1920s in the 1930s the last blocks
of resistance in Congress and the
Supreme Court gave way and they accepted
every imaginable economic regulation as
justified by Congress's power to
regulate commerce among the states it
was 75 years ago when President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt won a landslide
re-election victory and threatened to
pack the Supreme Court with six new
justices sympathetic to the New Deal
that all serious defense of economic
Liberty came to an end in April 1937 the
court accepted the National Labor
Relations Act commonly called the Wagner
Act by which the federal government
established an independent regulatory
agency the National Labor Relations
Board to promote labor unions in the
private sector for the time being it is
true that Roosevelt did not get to
expand the size of the Supreme Court and
that is outrageous proposal to do so
sparked such great popular and
congressional opposition as to put an
end to the New Deal but Roosevelt was
able to pack the court in the
old-fashioned way after deaths and
retirement and the post Roosevelt
Supreme Court buried economic rights
pretty effectively despite some
indication of a revival in the 1980s and
1990s the new constitutional position on
economic Liberty was expressed in a very
famous footnote to a decision in which
the Supreme Court have held a
congressional act prohibited prohibiting
the interstate shipment of filled milk
and this was the dairy Lobby at work
again the case was us versus Carolyn
products and the court said the
existence of Saks supporting the
legislative judgment is to be presumed
in cases involving ordinary commercial
transactions in economic regulation the
court would assume that legislation
rests upon some rational basis within
the knowledge and
experience of the legislators that is to
say the court would accept any but the
most wildly a rational basis for
congressional economic regulation but
the court said there may be narrower
scope for the operation of the
presumption of constitutionality when
legislation appears on its face to be
within a specific prohibition of the
Constitution such as those of the first
ten amendments which are deemed equally
specific when held to be embraced within
the 14th I got an illustration of
exactly what Alexander Hamilton warned
about when he argued against a bill of
rights saying now the presumption is we
assume Congress has the power and if
you're asserting a right you have to
prove it by the text of the bill of
rights this footnote also suggested that
the court would scrutinize statutes
directed a particular religious racial
or national minorities and would also be
alert to prejudice against discrete and
insular minorities which may be a
special condition which tends seriously
to curtail the operation of those
political processes ordinarily to be
relied upon to protect minorities and
which may call for a correspondingly
more searching judicial scrutiny simply
put some rights and some groups were
entitled to more constitutional
protection than others the doctrine
became known as the preferred freedoms
or the double standard test the court
has developed it largely by applying the
bill of rights to the states it is also
lately admitted in the it's abortion
jurisprudence that was applying the Due
Process Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment to the states what is called
substantive due process and which was
precisely what the progressives had
accused the court of doing before the
New Deal to protect economic rights the
difference with the new substantive due
process though is that it's used for the
right groups for the right rights and
applied by the right judges this post
new deal understanding of Rights is
really a redefinition of the very idea
of rights one can say that the
progressives continue to use the
founders vocabulary of Rights while they
turn the noun into its opposite labor
leaders in the 19th century often spoke
of the workers right through his job and
use this as a justification for the use
of violence and strikes or to argue that
unions should be exempt from laws that
apply to everyone else progressive labor
economist John R Commons thus argued
that the right to employment implied the
obligate
to provide jobs for workers this idea is
especially popular in academic circles
it is the fundamental argument of Cass
Sunstein a colleague of President Obama
at the University of Chicago Law School
and now our czar of regulation and the
author of the book the second Bill of
Rights FDR's unfinished revolution and
why we need it more than ever the second
Bill of Rights idea derived from two
famous speeches that FDR gave one at the
san francisco commonwealth club during
the nineteen thirty-two campaign and the
other is 1944 annual message to congress
in the commonwealth club address
Roosevelt spoke of the advent of
enlightened administration which would
redistribute resources in accordance
with an economic declaration of rights
in his 1944 message Congress Roosevelt
said that our rights to life and liberty
the rights of the original Constitution
have proved had proved inadequate to
assure us equality in the pursuit of
happiness he claimed that in our day
these economic truths have come to be
accepted as self-evident we have
accepted so to speech a second so to
speak a second Bill of Rights this bill
of rights included the right to a job
the right to food and recreation the
right to adequate farm prices the right
to a decent home the right to medical
care and the right to a good education
of course these are not rights at all
not in the sense of the framers and
ratify errs of the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution use
the term but they are more properly
called entitlements from the founding
until the 20th century the American
regime assumed the government's purpose
was to secure pre-existing natural
rights life liberty property Association
everyone can exercise that right
simultaneously nobody's exercise of his
own rights limits anyone elses similar
exercise your right to life were to work
or to vote does not take anything away
from anybody else we can all pursue
happiness at once entitlements on the
other hand requires someone else to
provide me with the substantive good the
right to work for example it's
fundamentally different from the
entitlement to a job the right to marry
does not entitle me to a spouse and the
right to free speech does not entitle me
to an audience the New Deal is often
described as a constitutional revolution
it was in fact much more than that it
involved the rejection not just that the
structure and principles of the
Constitution but those of the Lockean
theory of natural rights in the
Declaration of Independence that is
Jefferson put it governments are
instituted to secure our rights
Roosevelt and vision not a new
constitution but a new idea of what
Professor Sunstein calls a nation's
constitutive commitments the first bill
of rights in the second bill of rights
are simply incompatible the achievement
of the second requires the repeal of the
first as to this problem professor
Sunstein says that the best response to
those who believe that the second bill
of rights does not protect rights at all
is just this unembarrassed evasion
there's a reason why people don't want
to admit what's going on here
intellectually you can see the way this
works out in the current debate over
health care the reason why such things
as death panels and rationing are
inescapable when government takes over
health care is because we will be
sacrificing the health of some
individuals for the sake of greater
social health this is a utilitarian
calculation and utilitarianism denies
that individuals have rights that cannot
be violated even if that sacrifice
produces a greater good for a greater
number Ezekiel Emanuel health care
adviser to President Obama insists that
we need to quote redefine a physician's
duty that now includes working for the
greater good of society instead of
focusing only on an individual patients
needs intellectuals like Peter Singer
the Princeton asset ethicists who was
argued in favor of infanticide already
with the calculations and formulas such
as quote quality adjusted life years
which he explained that an article
entitled why we must ration health care
this is what happens when we call
healthcare a right and the confusion of
rights and entitlements is the chief
legacy of New Deal liberalism for
decades now we've been following the
path of thomas hobbes who explained that
we must surrender all of our natural
rights to an all powerful sovereign
rather than that of John Locke who
argued that the sovereign power of the
government was limited to the protection
of our pre-existing natural rights so
that's the story of how we lost the
founders idea of economic liberty and
let me stop there and take take your
questions
thank you dr. Moreno I'm actually asking
question on behalf of Tanya who says
like every good American I think that
equality is one of our foundational
principles but it seems to come into
conflict with another important
principle and that is Liberty she says
then she asked is there a conflict
between the two such that we often look
to equality before we look to liberty
that's an excellent question and it's
one that I think throughout the history
of politics people have wrestled with
and and Alexis de Tocqueville made the
observation that Americans were they
love Liberty and loved equality but the
tendency of democratic people's was too
if they have to make a choice to prefer
equality and that was a really great
danger the democracies have always been
prone to is why don't the many just vote
themselves the property of the field
that's sort of and the founders
understood that they read the stories of
the fall of the democracies of the
ancient world and part of the way in
which the Constitution tries to limit
democracy that the majority can't just
do whatever it wants is what the
Constitution is uh is meant to do that
we are you know that that majority the
will of majority is not enough to
justify houses Lincoln said a
constitution that does change in cord
with public opinion but nevertheless a
constitution needs to be something that
limits the sovereign power of a majority
in a philosophical sense though I think
you said people put equality before
liberty and I think that's that's right
equality is the basis we start with the
proposition that all men are created
equal and it's from that basic equality
that no one is by nature entitled to
rule another person that the principles
of Liberty follow from so the Equality
I'd say is prior to delivered but it has
to be equality properly understood as
Lincoln said the founders believed that
the principle of human equality of
course condemned slavery but it doesn't
mean that all people are equal in all
respects and the classical distinction
between equality opportunity on the one
hand and quality outcomes is the
fundamental difference just as when we
talk about liberty the difference
between Liberty and license is
one that we need to keep in mind Kenneth
Spence from Dallas Texas do you think
that the bourgeois virtue of the
founders that you mentioned at the
beginning um would do you think that a a
level of virtue higher than that would
have provided a legal foundation for a
non positivist view of law that could
have stemmed the tide of progressive
legal decisions since the slaughterhouse
cases more effectively than the sort of
much more basic ethics of the founders I
think that the first part about there
being a kind or view of virtue that is
higher than that of the bourgeois
virtues right so yeah that's absolutely
necessary and the idea is that there are
some people who are not going to be
satisfied with the near you know getting
and the the satisfying of material wants
there are going to be people whose
ruling passion is honored for example
and Lincoln talks about this and one of
his first speeches where he says merely
preserving the kind of Republic that the
founders established isn't enough
they're going to PB people of the the
tribe of the eagle and the lion will
stop at nothing to establish their their
fame and their greatness and certainly
if you were nothing more than a nation
of shopkeepers we would probably fall
before nations that preserved sort of
other kinds of virtues the Marshall
virtues in particular so you're going to
need those as well if you're going to be
able to to survive in a world where not
every nation is founded on the same
principles that ours is but I don't
think I got quite got the second part of
what you're talking about how that would
have stemmed the progressive view legal
developments right so so if if
the progressive legal view being the
might makes right sort of positivists
and and the the alternative to that
being law with based on some sort of
natural morality do you think if if the
sort of the morality of the founding had
been something more substantial than the
birth wat virtue that that could have
provided a stronger morality from which
to base a sort of natural natural law of
view of our jurisprudence well I think
if you look at homes you have an
interesting illustration where here's a
guy who believed very deeply and what
Lincoln said was a sort of the pre
constitutional principles of equality
and liberty the slavery was just was
just wrong and Lincoln in his debates
with Douglas was warning against exactly
that kind of positivist you know sort of
philosophy of precipitous that might
makes right and homes believe that he
was a great man going into the war the
problem was that he came out of the war
denying that right denying the idea of
ice and the homes of was was not not
everybody came through the experience
that homes did many people are not
disillusioned by the war and continued
to believe in the principles of the
founding in fact there was a revival of
natural law jurisprudence in the late
19th century which which built upon the
revival of natural law that Lincoln I
had applied in the Civil War so i think
it was it was there all along yeah the
founders making room for the bourgeois
virtues didn't they did not mean to
exclude the kind of martial virtues that
i think quite rightly homes and Theodore
Roosevelt tell that you know within a
dangerous world it's nice to have some
citizens who have some martial virtues
I'm Katie batchelder I'm a student at
Hillsdale College my question is how
does the 17th amendment affect the
United States and how are we still a
union if the Federals if the states
don't have direct representation in the
federal government so that's that's
another excellent question in a way the
yeah the progressives idea also was one
of unvarnished democracy right they
disputed that all of the constitutional
mechanisms were built into the
Constitution that in any way infringed
upon them
ah cracy they were opposed to so they
prefer things like the not only the
direct election of senators but the
recall of elected officials the
referendum and the initiative one of the
biggest controversies with regard to
property rights was Theodore Roosevelt's
proposal in 1912 that we be able to
recall unpopular judges or judicial
decisions especially that affected
economic regulations so the seventh the
men would be part of this attempt by the
progressives to do away with anything
that could limit the will of the
majority right so i think that the
federal element within the seventeenth
amendment was just one way in which the
Constitution tried to make democracy
workable and by giving the states as
states a place within the the
constitutional system that was a very
important way in which you limited the
power of just sort of national
majorities it was even to this day the
American people have still never acted
as one you know aggregated mass we
always we still act with the Norris
within our state's when we act so I'm
the idea of having the direct election
of senators if you wanted a sort of an
unlimited democracy well then why would
you have still these senators represents
so such disparate populations well I
have the people Delaware elect to
senators and have the people of
California elect to senators you really
were a thoroughgoing Democrat then you'd
have to do away with the other part of
equal suffrage in the Senate and you
can't do that without getting Delaware's
own consent which they're not likely to
give so in a way it was an impossible
part of the progressive project of
unshackling democracy the real the real
claim that progresses made was that the
state legislators who chose the Senators
had become the tools of big business and
of the political parties and it's the
sort of those were the real targets of
the progressives in the 17th amendment
so it would be certainly a way of
restoring limited government and a
federalism to you know if we didn't have
the 17th amendment was one of the
principles of the founders recognized
and economically turned out to be the
case was what's sometimes called
competitive federalism that s one state
wanted to experiment in some kind of
social or economic legislation that
was economically counterproductive
business would have the option of moving
to another state where the the climate
was friendlier and that principle is
given way to national standards that
forbid the states to compete with one
another in the economic market and the
replacement of competitive federalism is
so-called cooperative federalism is
another step towards a certain
centralization and nationalization of
economic questions thank you this
question comes from Linda who is one of
our online viewers she says I often hear
that the founders envisioned America as
a commercial Republic does the
Constitution enshrine the free market as
the basis of the American Republic that
term the commercial republic is one
that's used by the scholars from whom I
took many of these ideas and essentially
yes they they could written there were
some of american founding generation
people like samuel adams who said oh the
american revolution here's our chance to
purge ourselves of corrupt commercial
interests right and we can establish the
united states that he called it as a
christian sparta right and there was
this debate and it's in the founding
period and you do find people who's sort
of commitment to classical ancient ideas
was so great that they really imagined
america reviving some of those classical
principles but i think the predominant
view among the founders was no we were
already too far gone yeah we've already
become a commercial people and the
recognition of again the sort of the the
moral and social benefits of sort of
acquisitive economic activity makes the
American Founding more modern and I want
to emphasize that the connection was not
lost completely at Madison in red which
number the federalist paper says you
know there we are basing this
constitution on this idea that i think
is congressman spence put it that human
nature is fixed and it's flawed right
and we have to have protections against
human vice you know we don't build
governments on the basis that men or
angels and we can't turn them into
angels nevertheless he said there is a
sort of minimum
virtue that Republican governments
require that needs to be cultivated and
developed I think Madison's belief was
that a free market and extended market
especially in the economy would would
promote those kinds of virtues Adam
Smith made the arguments in more
explicitly in the wealth of nations and
again the founders were familiar with
this sort of moderate enlightenment of
the of the Scots especially Madison also
used the argument for religious
toleration on the same grounds that
religious liberty would be most
protected where you had a proliferation
of religious freedom and religious sects
no one of them would be likely to apress
the others and so it took a long time to
overcome the the Western idea that there
ought to be one orthodox church
established as Massachusetts still had
in this in the 1780s to this idea that
religion would actually benefit from
religious liberty so I think they also
recognize that politics republicanism
could also benefit from economic liberty
the classical view that was very
suspicious of commerce of luxury
acquisitiveness being morally corrosive
and leading to you know well effeminacy
was the term that they always always use
that man a decadence but the American
regime I think the American founders
didn't have to be that way and thats did
make us a distinctly modern republic
this will be our final question it comes
from an online viewer all from
Albuquerque he asked it appears to me
that federal control over the economy
has followed the heels of terrible
Supreme Court decisions what is the best
way for the American people to overturn
and rollback blatantly unconstitutional
rulings another another good question
they did the Supreme Court was once
again sort of the last holdout and
really is sort of the 1937 term where
the Supreme Court finally gives way and
says there are no longer you know any
any limits to what Congress can do it
would be difficult to well actually
there was a start in the 1980s and 90s
under the rehnquist quirk where they
began to breathe life into those parts
of the constitution that explicitly talk
about a property rights the first of
these was the takings Clause of the
Fifth Amendment oh it's sure that if you
read the bill of rights most of the Bill
of Rights do have to do with
non-economic rights Criminal Procedure
things freedom of speech and things like
that but there is the takings clause in
the Fifth Amendment and that provided
the the basis on which if the argument
is that the preferred freedoms are those
that are actually mentioned in the Bill
of Rights well there you've got one that
does protect economic rights and the
states have taken that further many
states now have standards that protect
property against taking even more
vigorously than the federal courts Dale
so there are places in the Constitution
where you could on a textual basis
revive the defense of economic Liberty
but ultimately don't count on the courts
for too much yeah there's only so much
they can do unless the political
branches and the citizens and voters are
awakened that need to take the principle
economic liberty more seriously it has
to be the political ones rather than the
judiciary I think the courts have been
it's been exaggerated how much they
defended property rights you know 100
and so years ago I think they are
contribution to a lot of the dismantling
of other elements of the police power in
the more recent years has also been
exaggerated so III think conservatives
often stake too much on how much courts
can do and it's based on a mistaken
belief and how much they've done
you